[Música]
a una veintena de kilómetros de vendôme
marín helen wason es la única artesana
de arte que se dedica únicamente a la
marquetería vol esta técnica busca
incrustar decoraciones realizadas en
latón o escamas de tortugas en muebles
antiguos este saber hacer cuenta con un
renombre mundial desde la época del bis
la técnica de la marquetería google
existe desde finales del siglo 17 andrés
chaves pool es quien la condujo a este
nivel de perfección pero no es su
inventor existía antes en alemania
andrew de chatswood quien es un ebanista
de finales del siglo 17 llegó esta
técnica a este grado de perfección marín
helen descubre la marquetería desde
temprana edad con sus padres
normalmente el latón no se corta así
se corta con una máquina pero mi padre
como empecé a cortar muy joven no quería
que usara máquinas porque quería que
conservará mis dedos
entonces me acostumbré a cortar en latón
así
para mostrar sus creaciones tan
singulares todos los años se dirige al
salón del patrimonio cultural en el
carrusel de luz en parís
[Música]
de hecho una primera y una contrapartida
en escama de tortuga latón y plata
adoro venir aquí porque me permite
mostrar mi trabajo y mi saber hacer me
permite igualmente ver lo que hacen los
demás es muy importante
entre los visitantes el ebanista de los
monumentos nacionales quien vino a
pedirle su opinión
una evidencia
y más que nunca
una marca de renombre
tener consejos técnicos de una verdadera
market era para mí que soy solamente
restaurador de mobiliario es para los
nacionales pero la idea es obtener un
consejo técnico y emprender cómo fue
cortado para ver si en efecto lo hizo un
aprendiz un marketer o profesional
mientras marín ln encuentran nuevos
clientes a algunos kilómetros de aquí
wason se prepara para retomar la
actividad en el liceo profesional de
hecho así les va
fui informado entre otros por su madre
quien me dijo quiero una sucesión y una
perpetuación del oficio ella me dijo
aurore sería bienvenida si la aceptas en
tu taller para poder justamente promover
la en el oficio de la marquetería
veo cosas que no había visto antes en el
taller de mi madre hay maneras distintas
de hacer y siempre es interesante
aprender para después saber lo que se
conserva o no
después del deseo ojo se reúne con su
madre frente a la escuela de pool donde
atiende a su formación una escuela
especializada en los oficios de arte es
que su madre conoce bien
para mí muchos recuerdos porque mi
abuelo hizo esta escuela hace mucho
tiempo tengo recuerdos mi padre me
contaba que atravesaba el barrio san
antón con una carreta hoy en día es
inimaginable mi padre aprendió en bus yo
atendí la escuela google en marquetería
cincelado y grabado y ahora aunque
también está en bull en dibujo
ornamental y grabado el próximo año
y quería que vinieras un poco conmigo
porque siempre es interesante estar en
contacto con los clientes entonces te
llevo
además de la formación escolar los
pasados días de la semana en la empresa
de su madre para descubrir todas las
facetas del oficio
aunque en este tipo de cajita que te
crees capaz de hacer actualmente creo
ser capaz de limpiarlas marqueterías
poner las mallas que faltan
cortar también
en el momento de los trabajos prácticos
se vuelve la obrera de su madre una jefa
amable pero exigente así que sin ella
estoy con mi hija querida objetivamente
estoy con mi hija querida sin embargo
cuando trabajamos trabajamos podemos
divertirnos etcétera pero si el pedazo
no está bien cortado sabe bien que voy a
volver a hacerlo está claro
este legado familiar se transmite sin
concesiones pero marín helen ha puesto
la pedagogía a la moda con un enfoque
menos riguroso que su padre
era más duro es decir que yo mi padre
tenía una gran mesa napoleón tercero
cuando quizá los 17 años ejercer este
oficio me dijo ya no hay marketer ya
empezaron de nuevo cuantas veces sea
necesario pero la cortas cojo cuenta con
una iniciación privilegiada pero marín
él en lo límite la transmisión de su
arte al círculo familiar
a través de talleres abiertos para todos
le enseña también a un público
insospechados
hemos podido en esta ciudad
también ingresa en el interior tómate tu
tiempo
era más duro no se guardaba todo no
decíamos nada es una lástima después es
un asunto de saber hacer perfecto si se
desenvuelve no puedo restaurar todos los
muebles de la tierra
tras cuatro generaciones el reemplazo en
la marquetería de bull está garantizado
la familia pozón sigue siendo soñar a
los apasionados de muebles antiguos con
su arte tan particular
[Música]